son las ocho y media de la mañana y como
todas la mañanas y para emigrar a
escuela a los catorce años está en la
cárcel y tiene dos años de retraso
porque bryant no es un estudiante como
los demás en 2019 con tu familia tuvo
que huir de su aldea en israel atacada
por hombres armados e incluso hoy le
recuerda cuando los hija distas atacaron
nuestra aldea yo estaba en la escuela y
huí para advertir a mis padres
he estado aquí dos años pero solo puedo
de inscribirme en la escuela de este año
formando mis cuales siendo
aquí aprenden oficio de la mecánica
consejos me animan y hacemos actividades
como bailar
[Música]
ibrahim y su familia se encuentran entre
los 400.000 desplazados internos en la
región son torno t en un país con más de
un millón en este campamento creado por
el estado burkinés se ha integrado en el
espacio dedicado al seguimiento
psicológico de los niños creado por
unicef hay un promedio de 300 bandadas
cada día los niños llegan en un estado
psicológico muy difícil porque en su
mayoría han sido testigos o víctimas o
se han visto afectados por las
dificultades asociadas con el
desplazamiento por lo que este espacio
les brinda la oportunidad de mantener un
nivel de aprendizaje y conciencia
mientras esperan los pasos a seguir para
poderlo inscribirse en la escuela los
profesores también sobre el objetivo de
los grupos yihadistas desde intimidación
amenazas hasta adicción a jugar en
scripts al de corte los profesores
también con el objetivo de los grupos y
artistas desde intimidación amenaza
hasta asesinato la la máquina de
software se deshace a motorhead
irrupción donde las filas han abatido el
personal del director del alcohol
pública en la vital
el salido y salir fútbol línea de la
entidad esto provocó el cierre de más de
2.000 escuelas principalmente en el
norte y este de burkina pasó incluso hoy
en día algunos profesores de la región
de staël son víctimas de la inseguridad
este el caso de esa mira cuando una
mañana hombre armados que llegaron a su
escuela
había seis de ellas cinco vestían
equipos de combate y uno vestía de civil
así le dio una bofetada a mi compañero
de trabajo y fue entonces cuando la dijo
que mirara para otro lado y luego mi
compañero de trabajo fue hablada por uno
de ellos
e
para el no gritaba pero después cuando
nos dejaron empezó a gritar y unos
avales de axila están en contra de todas
de todo todo todo
desde este ataque también a él víctima
del síndrome de estrés postraumático sí
llanta
grande ya no soy yo
10 de un mes
estuve dos semanas y dos días sin poder
cerrar los ojos y la nariz para ver
consecuencias fisiológicas difíciles de
borrar dentro de este sindicato de
maestros abogan por el establecimiento
de un apoyo psicológico para los
maestros automatizados
y dance de personas son tomates muchos
profesores están traumatizados por la
situación
e incluso cuando se reabrieron sus
escuelas
no siempre recibieron apoyo psicológico
cuando fueron atacados cuando fueron
traumatizados para estabilizarlos
mentalmente
para que pudieran reanudar las lecciones
de manera serena
no percibimos medidas que aseguren que
mañana será el final del túnel
así que
dime
efecto de luz mucho y sin él
por parte de las autoridades de burkina
faso se asegura que el seguimiento
psicológico de los docentes afectados es
una prioridad
ese es ansia el que esto es fundamental
porque mientras el trauma esté ahí el
maestro no puede darlo todo por sí mismo
no puede enseñar en algunos casos por lo
que es realmente importante
acompañado de esto en general cuando hay
situaciones que se presentan los
recibimos intercambiamos con estos
profesores y les preguntamos a algunos
donde quieren ir y se reubican
tenemos 2200 establecimientos cerrados
por lo que lamentablemente no puedo
decir que la situación haya mejorado
fundamentalmente de hecho vemos sobre el
terreno que ha habido muchas mejoras en
el plan de seguridad pero lo que me
preocupa es más el vínculo con la
reanudación de actividades
si bien desde hace un año está crisis de
salud se ha sumado a la crisis de
seguridad desde el último año escolar
genera virtud 397 escuelas en burkina
faso esto permitió que casi 70 mil
estudiantes que reanudarán las lecciones